as we mark a year of the pandemic we're
focusing on stories of
progress from those dark early days this
time last year
new york city was the epicenter of the
virus in the u.s
since then close to one in 11 new
yorkers
has been diagnosed with the virus around
one in 300
has died from it hospitals were overrun
a year ago
due to a virus we did not understand
then and our lead national correspondent
david begno was on the front lines david
good morning you went back to one of
those hospitals david
just this week we did when we first
visited the brooklyn hospital center
last april
you know the outbreak in new york city
was nearly at its peak of the 900 covet
patients it treated
in the past year 700 of them came
through the doors between
march and may of 2020. so they got hit
really early on
now during that time ppe was very scarce
in fact i'll never forget
when we went inside the hospital i was
head to toe
in protective gear and one of the nurses
looked right at me and said
i want what you have i just remember
turning around and looking at you and
thinking to myself
is she really wearing a garbage bag
early in the pandemic i think
our institution as well as every other
institution in the world
was blindsided that is nurse kimberly
ellis when we met her a year ago at the
start of the pandemic
look at what he has on look at what i
have one she was treating covet patients
dressed like this
i was wearing a garbage bag over my
uniform
and you came in with a beautiful
moon suit and a mask dressed like you
were going to space
i remember how direct you were when you
looked at me and said what are you
wearing
initially it was very painful because
you guys looked like you were dressed
safer than we were at the time i would
like a helmet like yours
or can we have helmets like this for all
of the staff i said i wanted what you
had
because you looked like you were better
prepared for the pandemic
but in all fairness i don't think
anybody was prepared properly
in the early part of the pandemic but
we're past those early days
and things have changed dramatically for
nurse ellis
yes we'd like you to be here 5 30 a.m
tomorrow morning well she's back in her
original role
in the pre-operative department after
six weeks in the icu last spring
and across the hospital the number of
coveted patients is down
substantially let us get back to the
things we normally do which is taking
care of all the other medical problems
that people of brooklyn have
dr joshua rosenberg is the hospital's
infection control director
and he's an icu physician last year he
took us through one of their three
coded icus so this is the one-year
checkup
yeah what's the evaluation i'm grateful
how well we've survived
we had no clue what we were getting into
that but what's interesting is that
as all the data has come out through the
various research studies
a lot of the stuff we were doing back
then they're recommending now
and i'm still looking at this saying
it's not completely done yet nurse ellis
feels the same way about the virus that
it's not over yet and she says she will
never forget the fear
of those first days patients died
much more rapidly and often than i had
ever seen in my life
what was your worst day i think
every day was a challenging day we were
afraid
it was business as usual professionally
but it wasn't business as usual mentally
and emotionally
what didn't we see that went on behind
the scenes the sadness
i think the tears maybe even the
aggravation
and the frustration with what the
unknown
covet 19 has been the virus of the
unknown
the day after nurse ellis said to me
last april i want what you have
i sent her my face shield right after we
left the hospital our team agreed
it's the right thing to do she told me
she wore it every day at work
for all of the six weeks she spent in
the icu and
she never she never really forgot that
moment of
of seeing somebody walking in as a guest
of the hospital
better dressed than she was right so she
never got covered by the way that's good
and she's fully vaccinated you must feel
good to know that david i remember that
story very well
when i saw you in that in that getup i
thought god that does seem
a lot but it was very alarming because
nobody knew what we were dealing with
exactly including the medical community
it's hard to look at those pictures
realize even then in real time we didn't
know what is happening here
just remember the key is they made a lot
of progress last year it was such a
scary time to send on that note made a
lot of progress thank you david good to
see you